dans ma femme
il n'a jamais été des grands manuel
demande de monter une chaise qui
cheveux par contre on est des mots du
bon vendeur
c'est le père en fils mon grand père
vendait de produits ménagers au porte à
porte
mon père vendait de l'acier mon frère
avant les autos qui moi aujourd'hui je
vous vendre l'idée violence en enfer
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est le moment
idéal pour devenir entrepreneur
cette réponse là s'adresse à tout le
monde dans la salle mais tout
particulièrement aux étudiants
universitaires qui sont toujours sous
les bancs d'école je crois vraiment que
c'est le timing parfait pour ces
startups je vous le prouver
quant à l'université ce moment parfait
pour dénicher son associé ou pour monter
son équipe de rêve
à force de faire des projets des équipes
de travail des associations étudiantes
rails dans les comités on peut voir avec
qui on aime travailler pv qui ont une
chimie c'est exactement ce qui m'est
arrivé dans la première session maîtrise
ici j'avais à monter une start up de 0 à
1 d'un cours d'entrepreneuriat j'ai eu
le privilège de travailler
alexandre fabre toulon de la session je
me disais maudit qui braillent saguenay
qui est plaisant qui est un pied posé
assez surprenant vu que les français
vous me direz mais quand on a eu la
décision de se lancer en affaires c'est
vraiment pas été compliqué dire oui à ce
qu'on savait déjà qu'on avait des
compétences complémentaires qu'on avait
une chimie ensemble
malgré ce que plusieurs étudiants disent
l'horaire comptes aux études c'est pas
un plus flexible quand tu fais du 40
heures dans un cubicule suffit de passer
un peu moins tan dung quat à 7 le jeudi
puis dans les pubs le vendredi je prends
un certain jean chistophe l'autre point
qui est important sur le pod
d'obligations familiales qui peut rester
jusqu'à minuit le soir au bureau ce
n'est pas le petit bonhomme qui va
t'attendre garderie un autre avantage on
est étudiant
c'est que les organisations sont
beaucoup plus facilement ça je peux le
prouver par une expérience personnelle
parce que moi puis alex on n'écrira pas
mal toutes les entreprises de la région
de montréal avec une adresse
professionnelle keynote address de notre
université
il tourne réponse n'est pas mal plus
élevé qu'on a découvert le travail de
hec les entreprises veulent aider les
étudiants fait que profiter à nos poilus
financiers
si vous êtes pauvres comme moi puis vous
prenez en vélo ou en métro puis que vous
êtes en colocation d'un cat ennemis mais
dites-vous que son avantage en soit
c'est pas mal moins compliqué de partir
sans revenus quand tu peux te demande
qu'on doit faire plus de paiement
automobile à tous et 1er du mois
j'ai parlé de l'aspect relationnel de
l'as fait flexibilité au niveau de
l'horaire de l'aspect financier mais le
point le plus important mon avis
l'aspect créativité afin de confronter à
tous les jours au nouveau modèle
d'affaires aux nouvelles technologies
aux nouvelles entreprises
mais ça permet de nous ouvrir une
nouvelle opportunité que sur le marché
juste dans le cours de transformation
numérique que je jouais à l'automne
passé j'ai dit avoir décidé de stand up
qu'est ce qui est bien aussi c'est qui
peut confronter des idées avec des
collègues de classe
tout le monde a son mot à dire tout le
monde a son opinion sur nouvelle star a
fait mieux encore les professeurs sont
ouverts pour vous donner un coup de main
j'ai quoi de mieux qu'un professeur
d'université en innovation pour
challenge et au modèle d'affaires
selon une récente étude du journal les
affaires on apprenait que 42 % des moins
de 35 ans voulait se lance en affaires
et créent leur entreprise
par contre quand on regarde les vrais
chiffres et seulement 16% des personnes
de moins 35 ans qui sont propriétaires
de jeunes entreprises
pire encore la moyenne d'âge est de 39
ans dans les propriétaires de jeunes pme
donc on voit qu il vraiment un gars
vouloir se lance en affaires il faut
vraiment de passer de 0 à 1
j'espère que ceux des conférences comme
celle d'aujourd'hui pouvons nous
permettre de changer ses statistiques
l'ensemble bon maintenant je suis
convaincu que c'est aujourd'hui le
meilleur moment pour son affaire si vous
qu'on fait ça dans l'imaginaire
collectif dans un bon vieux garage
qu'une start up née aux etats-unis s'est
rendu l'image le symbole fort de
l'entrepreneuriat c'est normal avec les
histoires de steve jobs de la ripelle
the walt disney dans le bon vieux garage
que à force de persévérance plus de
compétences ont réussi à surmonter les
obstacles pour monter sa start up
cette marge est rendue si fort que même
des entrepreneurs qui font des lieux de
pèlerinage avec ses six garages là par
contre en 2017 c'est fini le temps des
garages c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé ma
conférence sors de ton garage en 2017
faut arrêter de gagner ce créneau dans
le che nous puis conforté l'intrigué au
plus grand nombre de personnes possible
puis pour ce faire si les accélérateurs
les incubateurs une bonne nouvelle la
plupart des universités en possèdent un
on a qu'à penser à concordia que le
district 3 à le tfc agressé n'tech ou
plus près d'ici
l'accélérateur banque nationale avec la
chaussée montréal il ya de l'aide qui
est disponible un support qui est
disponible c'est à vous d'en profiter
c'est exactement ce que fait mon public
c'est notre stand up diffuse on a le
privilège de faire l'accélérateur banque
nationale de hec puis son père mort du
coaching du support puis des bureaux
gratuit puis quand entrepreneurs baptême
seules choses gratuites puis aussi
qu'est ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a pu
partager notre quotidien avec d'autres
acteurs qui vivent les mêmes réalités
que nous donc on ne peut faire des
échanges de meilleures pratiques
d'affaires
puis une déconseille donc en 2017
il faut conforter notre vie il faut
sortir de chez nous faut sortir de son
garage puis je vous invite à profiter
des dollars qui est disponible pourquoi
cela n'a fait pourquoi devenir
entrepreneur si vous demandez un
entrepreneur je vais vous dire ce la
question le plus important que vous
devez vous poser avant de faire le grand
saut
les réponses qu'on entend souvent c'est
l'argent que la notoriété
normal vous me direz les dix personnes
les plus riches de la planète sont tous
des enfants en des entrepreneurs il
toujours selon cette étude les 2 100
personnes les plus riches
aucun des salariés puis aucun employé ça
donne le goût n'est ce pas et que dire
du statut et le masque zuckerberg pour
nommer que ces deux là sont rendus des
superstars dans les médias puis d'un
point de vue historique de bill gates
physique et puis steve jobs qui sont
l'emblème même d'entrepreneuriat la
reconnaissance qui s'ensuit plus besoin
d'avoir le sourire de brad pitt ou les
lampes theunis d'eugénie bouchard est
invité sur les plateaux de télévision
il suffit seulement d'avoir cette
enveloppe mais si vous voulez mon avis
il faut des mots de façon beaucoup plus
grandes que ce site veut survivre dans
la jungle de l'entrepreneuriat selon une
récente étude de forbes
90% des starters mort dans la première
année dans existent pour cent qui reste
c'est en moyenne après 24 mois que les
fondateurs se verse un salaire
on est loin des parts et et caviar et
champagne sont des yaks dans mon cas
c'est pas mal plus burrito de leur
classe d'un cat et demi donc fouler des
motivations beaucoup plus grande que la
notoriété plage ans tu veux survivre au
temps pas être d'entrepreneuriat pour
plusieurs de mes confrères c'est
d'accord propre patron pour mon site et
aussi d'avoir un bébé d'un décret de 0,1
d'avoir un projet à lui pour moi puis
alex c'est pour innover pour changer le
statu quo
aider les étudiants qui sont dans
l'angoissé de la recherche d'un premier
emploi bon maintenant je vais convaincu
de vous lancer en affaires comme en fait
ça je vais quand même pas vous laisser
les mains vides je vous donnais un truc
pratico pratiques que vous pourriez
utiliser non seulement pour lancer votre
tracteur et aussi pour innover au sein
des organisations
le point le plus important à mon avis il
faut résoudre un besoin un besoin pardon
chez un consommateur ou chez votre
client c'est bien voir le produit plus
sexy possible ou d'avoir une plate forme
avec un algorithme complètement fou mais
si personne ne veut l'utiliser ou pire
encore personne ne veut payer pour
l'utiliser vous allez mourir ça vaut pas
être long puissamment mes plus grands de
ce monde l'oublient parfois je vous
donne un exemple concret les boules de
glace c'est qu'ici qui s'élevait à 5
heures du matin pour faire la file pour
les premières google glace hockey c'est
ce que je pensais donc on peut voir que
google au port répondent à un réel
besoin quand se produit juste pour ça
qu'on ne voit pas ses tablettes des
baisses bien sûr toujours selon l'étude
de forbes qui dénombrait l'hiver les
vins raison d'échecs en stand up c'est
sans surprise que la numéro 1 c'était le
manque de besoin sur le marché les 42%
des start up qui échoue parce qu'il crée
un produit ou un service dont personne
ne veut et où personne ne veut payer
pour
donc avant de vous lancer en affaires
assurez vous d'avoir un produit ou un
projet qui fait saliver les gens c'est
comme ça que vous allez réussir
je vous donne un exemple un peu plus
personnel montréal ex on a lancé le
stand up defuse en 2016
on avait pour ambition de révolutionner
le monde de l'industrie et veulent
sauver l'industrie du recrutement
universitaire en proposant un service de
chasseur de têtes virtuelle grâce à un
algorithme qu'on avait développé on
pouvait suggérer les cinq meilleurs
quand 2.9 de stage ou un oeuf d'emploi
notre potager est un moment l'heure
c'est que les recruteurs à être prêts à
payer pour le plus fort d'être suivi
donc on avait pensé temps argent en
ressources à développer notre site web
pinatel gorrite
puis un mois après notre lancement après
nombreuses en compte des call cale au
sentiment que personne ne voulait payer
notre service c'est à ce moment là qu'on
a dû faire un pivot jeter vim
ces mois de travail à la poubelle fait
recommencer à zéro pour faire une plate
forme dont les recruteurs vraiment c'est
jamais évident de faire ce
puis si je peux vous donner un conseil
quand vous rencontrez un client
potentiel
écoutez pas pour répondre écouter pour
comprendre pas c'est facile de tomber en
amour avec son idée donc quand lui à
faire notre pivot en instituant le
changement mais maintenant le
méthodologie d'innovation l'innovation
ouverte
c'est un sujet qui de plus en plus
trendy dans les écoles de commerce ou
dans les grandes entreprises
à quoi ça consiste nova sont ouvertes
c'est d'inclure un plus grand nombre de
parties prenantes dans ta conception de
produits concrètement lorsque d'inclure
tes clients et partenaires des
fournisseurs voire même des compétiteurs
dans ton développement de produits avec
nous ça va vraiment être un succès au
lieu de travailler tout seul dans le
coin mopelex qu'est ce qu'on a fait on
envoyait un sondage dans toutes les
universités du québec
vous avez sûrement reçu mon sondage
ailleurs on l'envoyait aussi à tous les
recruteurs avec une région de montréal
un succès 5800 étudiants qui ont répondu
à notre sondage puis 460 recruteurs ça
nous a permis de vraiment bien cibler
les besoins
qu'est ce qui faisait saliver les
recruteurs puis c'est quoi les
problématiques des étudiants ce à partir
de ce qu'on écrit et mieux encore j'ai
rencontré 60 tracteurs pouvoir bien
comprendre leur réalité
au début de chaque rencontre je leur
disais bon jeu là une baguette magique
ce serait quoi la plateforme de
recrutement tes rêves plus à partir de
ces suggestions le petit commentaire
lors qu'on le continue de produits qu'on
vole en silence de semaine d'ailleurs je
vous invite à aller vous inscrire donc
la morale de cette histoire le supplie
créer un produit aussi d'inclure un plus
grand nombre de personnes possible le
plus grand nombre d'acteurs possibles
parce que les différents angles analyse
les différents points de vue qui vont
vous permettre de vraiment créer plus de
générer des vraies innovations dany près
et conseils pratiques aux pratiques
ciblé réussir en stand up ou supply
réussir à innover il faut que vous soyez
préparé le facteur de numéro un qu'on
voulait vous voulez vous lever des
financements c'est pas la passion mais
c'est la préparation
quand vous êtes devant les investisseurs
potentiels des banquiers il faut vous
connaissez modèle d'affaires votre
proposition de valeur votre marché vos
clients comme le fond de votre poche pas
si la passion que la motivation vous
garder en vie jour après jour mais si le
travail la préparation qui ont failli
réussir
certains d'entre vous doivent trucks
assez ironique que je vous vendre l'idée
de vous lancer en affaires alors que
j'ai une plateforme de recrutement
mais la réalité est autre et aux biens
autrement de plus en plus d'entreprises
dont vous inviter à des entrepreneurs à
créer au sein a créé des petites
start-up au sein même des entreprises
c'est à ce moment là vous allez pouvoir
utiliser les conseils d'un point de vue
personnel ça fait un an que je me suis
lancé dans le monde de l'entrepreneuriat
ce serait vous mentir de vous dire que
c'est toujours rose bonbon
par contre cette expérience cette
expérience leur permet de sortir de ma
zone de confort jour après jour de vivre
des expériences formidables
c'est un ferme il est conférencier
qu'aujourd'hui ça m'a permis d'aller
rencontrer les clients potentiels en
europe de rencontrer des grandes figures
d'entrepreneuriat du québec comme alain
bouchard le cio de couche tard mais
surtout surtout ça me permet travaille
avec une équipe formidable
puis travaillé à tous les jours avec mon
meilleur ami pim la personne la plus
intelligente que je connaisse alex fait
qu'au final je vous invite à sortir de
votre garage à rencontrer le plus grand
nombre de personnes possible de bien
vous entourer parce comme aimé jacquet
le coach de france en 98 le si bien dit
le travail individuel ça vous permet de
gagner un match mais c'est l'esprit
l'équipe l'intelligence collective que
vous permettre dans une coupe du monde
sortez de vos garages les amis
[Applaudissements]